hey guys it's Justine and I have a
problem and I'm here to talk about it I
was back home visiting with family not
too long ago and that's about the time
the doctor Mario came out and since then
I had some free time so I thought okay
I'm going to allow myself to play this
mobile game thinking this isn't gonna be
dangerous
it'll be fine I'll just kill some time
this week and then I can go back to my
life and I could not be more wrong
because I wake up I'm thinking about
this game I thought asleep I'm thinking
about thing actually I play it before
bed and I play it as soon as I wake up I
can't stop it is so much fun so I just
wanted to show you guys a little bit of
game play and then Jenna actually tried
to have a little intervention with me so
you'll see that here in a minute but I'm
just gonna go through and play a stage
and just show you what the game is all
about if you haven't played it yet and
this is not sponsored because I've
actually spent my actual real money on
this game and probably spent way too
much I'm not proud of it so I'm
currently on level 128 so let's just go
through like this level and I'll show
you guys those games all about I always
like to put something underneath of it
because I eat a bit of leverage all of
those little guys float them to the top
okay well not much I can do about that
one I'm not enjoying this map very much
this is this is not a fun one
Here I am talking this game up and then
I'm playing this differently level let's
keep you out of there
let's get you
this gave us so silly like I love it so
much great whole squad is unlocked they
are ready that was a mistake
did not mean to do that I'm not happy
about it this is a bit of a predicament
here this is not my best game guys I'm
really pretty upset about it that could
not have been more perfect to be honest
with you this is working out great
except ah okay I'm gonna have to use a
hammer destroy this last one because
that because that's what I had to do
okay wait is a clear two level there's
also vs. and they're ranked play and I
am stuck at to your for right now like I
have to get to tier 5 but it's 1600 plus
points and I keep dying so much but once
you get around like 1300 everyone gets
really really good so I'm gonna play a
match here and hope I can get to 1600
within a week it was so good okay are
you ready
focus focus up this is where you have to
go super quick no mistakes you made
a mistake that was a mistake that was a
mistake I didn't mean to do it oh my
gosh oh my gosh this is terrible this is
terrible this is terrible this is
terrible this is awful absolutely
terrible oh my gosh I can do anything I
can do anything I'm champion so that's
what I've been doing with my time
we don't need any more reasons for you
to play the game the past week all she's
been doing is playing doctor Mario World
and I'm genuinely concerned about her
health like was it like could you buy it
how much money have you spent on this
game have you been working like I'm
worried I'm genuinely worried about it
has mommy been taking care of you don't
touch me don't you have like you have
you haven't problem give me that
I'll marry go hell I will put you to
sleep don't make me do it don't make me
don't you want to look give me the phone
don't oh we're done here now okay
you're not playing for tonight you're
playing what you're playing doctor
Temari of something so tomorrow world
get it right okay can I show you how
good I am fine can I show you how good I
don't even know it's a game is I just
think I have to be sitting I just don't
understand miss me that you're not gonna
touch it because this this will hurt my
right promise me okay I'm not gonna
touch it so basically I'm racing against
can you see what they're doing
oh you say you're winning you think
[Music]
Maddie's excited Shh focusing I'm
focusing you can't talk and it takes a
lot of focus can you see what their
ranking is Owen are let us be right this
is this one for every one of us who's
this and be so embarrassed because
everybody's here watching right now yeah
the whole internet did you just match
the colors that's that's fun
look I'm not a little 2002 dolls like I
get it I also this person is really good
oh shoot I just messed up oh my god one
mistake can it can really it can really
ruin you watch like live people don't
feel good like for guys
they're doing so well they're doing so
well why don't you I'm trying my hardest
very well do you think they spent for
enrollees in the game I want I want I
won I'm sweating so bad like they don't
understand even Maddie isn't playing dr.
Mario cuz he's been watching me play it
so much we go Maddie ready honey not
jamario time not youto him - oh my gosh
zip I've lost you both dr. Mario time
come on get those viruses Mattie get
them he's a higher level than you
him too I've lost them all
let's talk to Mario and just like guess
I'll download it
[Music]
[Music]